c'est vraiment une mauvaise initiative
vous le pensez vraiment nous bien sûr on
veut jamais en tant que président de la
fed de l'île aux enfants
vous n'auriez dû accepter l'idée d'un
tel concours je pense que vous avez
raison mon cher ami je crains en effet
d'avoir été quelque peu faible devant
l'insistance de casimir fallu françois
bonjour messieurs disney bonjour j'ai lu
bonjour ma très chère amie
ohlala vous m'avez l'air bien sombres
tous les deux dites moi j'espère que
vous ne vous êtes pas disputé devant nos
amis qui viennent d'arriver au pardon je
ne vous avais pas vus bonjour
veuillez me pardonner à mon tour je suis
enchanté de vous voir alors expliquez
moi ce qui vous rend si fut rien le
concours quel concours non tu n'es pas
au courant non dites le lui vous même
monsieur des snobs
oui et bien de notre cher ami c'est très
simple le camp le concours
voilà le concours enfin c'est à dire que
le le concours ça n'a pas l'air très
comme à disputer non pourtant très
simples messieurs 10 9 a organisé un
concours du plus gros mangeur de l'île
aux enfants sur l'existence de casimir
voyons monsieur du cela vous savez bien
comme il est très mauvais de manger
beaucoup c'est un concours stupide je
sais de plus casimir est assuré d'être
le vainqueur
souvenez-vous du ch concours de
choucroute après la finale le facteur
avait dû rester couchés deux jours mais
ça n'est pas par à digestion ils
n'avaient rien mangé
mais c'est vrai il avait été écoeurée
par tous que casimir l'état qu ajouter
dans la choucroute racour du moins ça je
ne m'en souviens pas eh bien il avait
rajouté dans la confiture de groseilles
de la crème chantilly dans de la
choucroute des fruits confits du beurre
du chocolat des cas des cornichons et de
la sauce tomate
j'ai arrêté méfiance avis je crois que
je me trouvais mal moi aussi malo alors
monsieur du ch 9 il faut être plus
résistante ça sent ça vous ne
supporterait pas la vue du plaid
kazimiyah mais je regrette mes chers
amis mais cette fois ci il s'agit ni de
choucroute ni deux mélanges bizarres au
répugnant car il y aura plusieurs
catégories
par exemple il y aura une catégorie de
chocolat puis un concours de bananes
il n'y aura aucun mélange spécial un
aucun casimir a dû être très déçu mais
non on compterait mettre xiam et s'est
lui-même cas qu'à fixer la liste des
différentes catégories d'ailleurs je ne
me souviens même plus casimir est lui
même
voilà qui n'est pas normal mes amis
bonjour je suis vraiment content de vous
voir salut casimir
nous sommes déjà vu ce matin je sais
c'est justement pour me préparer pour le
concours que j'ai besoin de vous trois
de nous trois voilà qui est inattendu
pour quoi faire et bien pour est sûr de
gagner tous les concours il faut que
j'ai très faim alors juil tu vas me
faire mes exercices de danse je vais
faire un peu de boxe avec toi françois
et une course avec vous monsieur le
store oui ce sera beaucoup trop casimir
mais oui c'est beaucoup trop abo voilà
j'ai compris vous refusé de m'aider à
gagner tous les concours
vous n'êtes pas des amis menault que
nous n'avons rien contre toi enfin alors
on commence tout de suite aller va vite
chercher les gants de boxe françois et
vous votre tenue de sport tu voudras je
me dépêche possible en position 2 à 2 à
2 à 2 à les compter du tout ça
as tu sais c'est fatigant jolie écoute
il faut que je me dépêche maintenant je
je vais mettre ma tenue de sport voilà
ça va regarde gauche à droite et percute
crochet ah oui j'allais le jeune zhang a
signalé l'agencé vous nombreux casimir
tenais ma chère a décidé de garder ceux
ci il s'agit de la liste des candidats
aux différents concours chapélies plus
vous en prie je suis fatigué mais j'ai
très faim ça marche et une seconde
casimir une seconde d'une peut parcourir
avec des gants de bottes house et bref
aulas on peut démarrer black ou aller
allons-y
allez allez allez
une preuve de plus voilà
alors quasiment 7 cost quand vous
n'étaient parfois je suis épuisé mais
j'ai une faim une fin terrible quand ça
marche j'ai fait j'ai une obsession du
snav
oui avez-vous fait bien attention à la
liste des concours avant marchera miriel
m'a paru anormal écoutez premier
concours chocolat oui c'est cela
2e concours confiture de fraises
troisième balade écrasé quatrième
moutarde
je parie que le 5e concours concernera
les plus gros mangeurs de saucisse de
toulouse cru mais tiède et comment avez
vous deviné et tous les concours auront
lieu en même temps
mais vous êtes un vrai de vin figurez
vous que ce nigaud de casimir qui a
décidé cela et il s'est inscrit dans
tous les concours justement il ne pourra
jamais faire les cinq concours à la fois
et bien le nigaud c'est vous monsieur
les snobs
que dites-vous que casimir rosa
bienvenus si vous mélangez du chocolat
en poudre de la confiture de fraises de
la banane écrasée de la moutarde
il la saucisse de toulouse cru mme
etienne vous obtenez du gloubiboulga
noeuds plats préférés de casino et
casimir affamés devant un gloubi boulga
géant est assuré de remporter les cinq
concours en même temps
[Musique]
c'est vraiment incroyable
pire que cela ma chère amie c'est
incompréhensible
tout a disparu je n'ai pu trouver que
ces restes pour faire le concours
dans ces conditions je vois mal qui
pourra empêcher casimir de tout gagner
le voilà justement
on n'allait pas bien du tout son visage
est tout pâle
me voilà je suis prêt je crois que j'ai
tout compris
je crois que moi aussi très bien nous
allons commencer le concours revient
qu'encourt le chocolat attention jacques
que tu es prêt on vient les gaz et mears
attention prêts partez oh quelle horreur
oh non je ne peux pas très bien jacques
becker radjabu deuxième concours à
troisième concours jambes la confiture
de fraises tu es prêt attention prêts
partez à les gens allaient tout ça non
j'y arriverai jamais il y en a pour les
gens bravo jean troisième concours
attention d'alpine labana d' écraser
attention très portée berck impossible
bravo delphine gardey nous passons
quatrième contre attention attention
franck la moutarde
après partez comment peut-on manger des
choses pareilles allez frank vainqueur
et nous passons au dernier concours la
saucisse de toulouse cru mais tiède
alors attention valérie attention kazemi
après partait à l'est
non non non rien que de voir ça je suis
malade
bravo valérie gagnante et valérie
alors qu'elle aimait explique toi mais
j'avais tellement forte alors que je
mangeais en un gigantesque gloubiboulga
avec ce que j'avais préparé pour le
concours exacte et tu es bien punis tu
n'a gagné aucun premier prix en paix
mais au fait j'y pense nous n'avons pas
vu le secteur c'est une curieuse un mois
je les rencontre et oui et quand je lui
ai annoncé que nous préparions un
nouveau concours du plus gros mangeur de
l'île aux enfants qu'il m'a dit je
préfère aller me coucher chez moi depuis
les partis chez lui quasiment
[Musique]